no man's sky has been under some
scrutiny since release but now there's
an actual investigation underway I'm
Tony and this is your spacefaring
GameSpot news update the UK's
Advertising Standards Authority is
investigating no man's sky but this has
nothing to do with the game's PR
campaign or big promises instead the
aasa' is looking at the game's steam
page the organization is investigating
videos that show off the games animal
and ship behavior flowing water effects
and space combat as well as graphics
quality the investigation is currently
underway so the aasa' cannot comment at
this time but will report back when we
hear more no man's sky released this
August and we gave it a fairly positive
seven out of 10 on GameSpot but review
scores are totally separate from how the
game presents itself on digital
storefronts like Steam so we'll have to
see how this investigation pans out and
if you want to keep up with all the
biggest video game news you're already
in the right place